Okay guys, here we go. We're at video 20
now. And in this one, I'm going to explain
the concept of beta. So why it's useful to
us and how we can calculate it at both the
equity level and the portfolio level as
well. I'm going to start by explaining
what beta is and why it's useful. And then
I'll move on to show you the model behind
beta using an Excel example.
Following that, we'll run through some
ways that you can calculate beta
yourselves, both as a snapshot value and
in the form of a time series for
individual stocks. And then at the end of
the video, we're going to look at how you
can use beta at the portfolio level to
give you an understanding of your market
exposure. And that's going to enable you
to make decisions about hedging and
position sizing within the portfolio.
So what is beta? Let me give you a
simplified version first. Essentially,
beta is a statistic that estimates the
economic sensitivity of a stock or a
portfolio of stocks to the market as a
whole.
And by definition, the market has a beta
value of 1. And basically, that acts as a
reference point from which individual
stocks beta is estimated around. So if an
individual stock has a beta of 2, then for
a given unit of return in the market, we
would expect the stock to move twice as
much in the same direction.
For example, if the stock market as a
whole increase by 1%, then we would expect
the individual stock to increase by 2% if
that stock had a beta of 2%.
Conversely, if the market decreased by 1%,
we would expect the stock to decrease by
2%. So the sort of increases and decreases
are magnified by a factor of beta.
So if a stock has a beta value of greater
than 1, what we can say about it is that
it's more economically sensitive than the
market as a whole.
And if it has a value of less than 1%, we
would say it's less sensitive.
Now, perhaps the easiest way to start
thinking about this is in terms of
cyclical and defensive equities.
So by definition, cyclical equities have
earnings that are economically sensitive
to the business cycle, which in turn means
that the price of those equities are also
sensitive to the business cycle.
So think of discretionary purchases like
travel, as an example.
If the economy is in a bad way, then it's
much less likely that consumers will spend
lots of money on vacations.
All else being equal then, we could guess
that these companies have a beta value of
greater than 1 because we would expect
that their stock prices are more sensitive
than the market as a whole to these
economic fluctuations.
And conversely, we can think of defensive
stocks like grocery stores at the opposite
end of the scale.
People need to buy groceries irrelevant of
the economic situation.
And so those companies are likely to be
less sensitive to economic fluctuations
than the market as a whole.
As a little detour for a moment, if you
take a look at the sheet I've got open
here, it contains details, including beta
values, on a large list of US equities.
And included in that list are almost 5,000
companies with GICS sector and industry
classifications, so that's G-I-C-S
classifications, along with market cap
data and beta values.
All of these values are accurate as of the
11th of September 2021.
And so most likely they aren't going to be
applicable for your own work in the
future, but I did want to include them
just so that you had an idea of what the
beta values for these companies were at
the time of filming.
As well as that, perhaps more usefully,
I've aggregated all of the stock data to
come up with market-weighted beta values
for every GICS sector, subsector, industry
group and industry.
And those values are unlikely to change
very much in the near future, so they will
give you a good idea of what sectors and
industries are sort of sensitive, more
sensitive and less sensitive to the
economic cycle.
Anyway, let me now dive in a little bit
deeper and talk to you about where the
statistic of beta that we're discussing
here actually stems from.
And it comes from a couple of different
financial models, namely the single index
model and the capital asset pricing model,
but they both use basically the same
theory.
The idea of these models is to explain the
returns of an asset using a single factor,
so the returns of the market.
And any error or excess return in these
models is identified as either sort of
firm-specific risk or something called
alpha, depending on the model and the
context in which it's being used.
None of that stuff sort of really matters,
all we're concerned with here is that we
can create a simple model that estimates
how much a stock moves in relation to the
market based on past data.
That gives us a value called beta, and we
can then use that number to accomplish
various things like hedging risks or
understanding portfolio exposure, position
sizing and volatility estimation.
And we're going to be doing some of that
stuff later in the video through some
practical Excel work.
Okay, I've made a lot of references to the
market so far, and you might be wondering
what I actually mean by that.
Basically, when I say the market, I
typically mean the whole equity market
that's related to the stock that we're
analysing.
So for US stocks, that would be the US
equity market.
Now, it's not very easy to get returns
data for the entire US stock market on
aggregate.
And so what we can do is use an
approximation for the market by looking at
the returns for US stock indices like the
S&P 500.
And as it turns out, the S&P 500 is
actually a pretty good approximation for
the market as a whole, because it accounts
for the majority of economic output of
listed companies.
So let's have a look at the spreadsheet
now, and to start things off, I'm going to
talk about something called a simple
linear regression model, which defines an
equation with which we can then retrieve
beta from.
Okay, as you can see here, there's four
sheets in this workbook, which, by the
way, you'll be able to download yourselves
in the downloads area for this video.
We're going to work from right to left
here, starting with calculating beta at
the individual asset level, and then
moving up to the portfolio level at the
end of the video.
All right, so let's look at this equity
beta sheet first, and I'll explain what's
going on here.
What we've got is a sheet prefilled with
weekly prices and returns for the S&P 500
and two stocks, Sanderson Farms and Fluor
Corporation.
Prices are in columns B to D, and returns
are in columns E through G.
On the right-hand side of the sheet, there
are some short company descriptions for
each stock, and they describe the sort of
business that they're in.
So if you take a look, Sanderson Farms is
basically a poultry company, whilst Fluor
Corporation is an engineering business.
Now, in the middle of the sheet, I've got
a scatterplot chart showing the weekly
returns data for both Sanderson Farms and
the S&P 500,
where Sanderson Farms returns are plotted
on the y-axis, and S&P 500 returns are
plotted on the x-axis.
So each dot on the chart basically
represents a weekly observation for the
two sets of returns.
So for example, if we look at the 25th of
June observation here, we can see that
Sanderson Farms returned 24.61% that week,
and the S&P 500 returned 2.74%.
In the chart, that would be one of these
dots that you can see around here.
And we know that because if we look across
from those points to the y-axis, you can
see the return value for Sanderson Farms
is around 25%.
Whilst if we look down from those points
to the x-axis, you can also observe that
the value for S&P returns is around 2.5%.
As well as the dots representing each
weekly observation in our data, I've also
got a black dotted line running through
all of these points,
which actually represents what's called a
simple linear regression line.
That line's calculated by minimizing the
summed squared vertical distances between
all observations and their means,
which is known as the ordinary least
squared method.
However, you know, you guys don't really
need to know that.
You guys can just think of it basically as
a line of best fit through all of this
data.
Anyway, that line can be represented by an
equation known as the regression equation.
And in this example, I've written that in
the top right of the chart.
So the equation is y equals 0.5656x plus
0.0022.
Now, for those of you that can remember
back to your high school maths,
you'd know that this equation is in the
form of a straight line.
When I was at school, we learned that in
the form of y equals mx plus c,
where every y value could be worked out as
some coefficient m multiplied by the
related x observation plus some constant.
So what does that actually mean?
Well, our y observations here are our
Sanderson farm returns and our x
observations are S&P 500 returns.
So the model equation estimates on average
that the returns for Sanderson farms are
equal to multiplying the S&P 500 returns
over the same period by 0.5656 and adding
0.0022 or 0.22%.
Now, remember earlier when I described
what beta was.
It's essentially a measure of sensitivity
of a stock's returns to the market or the
S&P 500 in this case.
So the value of sensitivity here can
simply be measured by calculating the
gradient of this line,
since that represents the change in
predicted Sanderson farm returns given a
unit change in S&P 500 returns.
The gradient of a straight line is just
the coefficient of the equation before the
x observation.
So in the case of the slope or gradient
here, it's 0.5656.
That means, for example, if S&P 500
returns are expected to increase by 5%,
then Sanderson farms returns would be
expected to increase by 5% multiplied by
that 0.5656 number, which is about 2.8%.
So let's go through a quick calculation
example using the equation just to
reinforce that concept.
If our x value, S&P 500 returns, that is,
measures 0%,
then the regression model equation we have
predicts that our y value, which is our
Sanderson farm returns,
should be equal to 0.5656 times by 0 plus
0.0022, okay?
And that is obviously just the constant at
the end, which is 0.22%.
If the S&P 500 return measures 5%, then
our regression equation predicts that
Sanderson farms return
should be 0.5656 times 5% or 0.05 plus
0.0022, which equals 0.03 roughly or
3.048%.
And you can see there that an increase in
S&P 500 returns of 5% led to a predicted
increase
of about 2.8% in Sanderson farm returns.
Now, hopefully all of that made sense, but
basically what I've done here
is generate a simple linear regression
line using the returns data we have for
the S&P 500 and Sanderson farms.
The equation for that line represents a
model that aims to predict the returns for
Sanderson farms
based on the returns over the same period
for the S&P 500.
The gradient of the line tells us the
sensitivity of Sanderson farms returns to
the S&P 500,
which is simply the coefficient of our X
values in the equation.
So in this case, that value is 0.5656.
And that is our estimation of beta.
Since that value of beta is less than 1,
it means we should expect Sanderson farms
returns to be less economically sensitive
than the market as a whole,
as represented by the S&P 500 index.
And more specifically, it predicts, given
the underlying data set that we've used,
that any change in returns for Sanderson
farms will be equal to around 0.5656
multiplied by the change in returns seen
in the S&P 500 over the same period.
Okay, don't worry at this stage if I've
lost you.
Realistically, all you need to know here
is how to calculate beta for a stock,
which I'm going to show you now,
and also what beta represents, which we've
kind of been through already.
So to that end, let me drill this home
though one more time.
Beta represents the economic sensitivity
of an asset.
And by definition, the market has a beta
value of 1.
And so any stock that has a beta of over 1
is said to be more economically sensitive
than the market.
So think cyclical sectors.
And any stock with a beta of less than 1
is said to be less economically sensitive
than the market.
So think defensive sectors.
If a stock has a beta of 1, it means that
a simple linear regression model predicts
that for every 1% change in returns for
the market,
there will also be a 1% change in returns
for the stock.
If a stock has a beta of 0.5, then we can
estimate for every 1% change in return in
the market,
there is a 0.5% change in returns for the
stock in the same direction.
And that's a key point here.
When beta values are positive, it means
the changes will be in the same direction
as the market.
In the unlikely scenario that you
calculate a negative beta,
then that would suggest that changes in
stock returns move in the opposite
direction to changes in market returns.
Okay, so you'll be pleased to know now
that I'm done clarifying beta.
So let's move on to how to calculate it in
Excel now.
And we can do this in a number of ways.
The first way I'm going to show you is via
a scatterplot chart, as I've done here
with Sanderson Farms,
except this time I'm going to go through
the whole process of creating the chart
and the equation for Fluor Corporation.
Although this is, you know, by no means
the quickest way of estimating beta,
it will teach you a few more things about
charting in Excel.
And I think it's always handy, really, to
be able to generate scatterplot charts,
given it's a great way of visualizing and
understanding data and relationships
between variables.
And, you know, that knowledge can be
translated to other applications as well,
so other data analysis applications.
So to begin with, I'm just going to select
cell I-21 and then go to insert on the
ribbon and choose to insert a scatterplot
chart.
Once that's done, I'm going to get a blank
chart area appear and I'm just going to
move and resize that so that it looks
roughly the same as the Sanderson Farms
chart area above.
And then we're going to right-click within
that chart area and go to select data to
add the data series that we need.
To do that, I'm going to click the add
series button on the left-hand side.
The series name is just going to be FLR
versus SP500 returns.
Okay, that's just because we're plotting a
scatterplot chart of our weekly
observations for Fluor Corporation versus
S&P 500 returns here.
Now, our X values are going to be our
market returns, our S&P 500 returns, and
our Y values are going to be our stock
returns.
And that has to be the case whenever
you're calculating beta.
Y values are always going to be stock
returns.
X values are always going to be market
So, our X values are going to run from
cell E2 down to cell, I think, E2000 and
something.
Okay, so cell E2,165.
The reason why I'm making the range down
to that row is so that it matches the
length of our Fluor Corporation returns.
Okay, and when you're doing analysis like
this, the ranges, the arrays that you pick
always have to be the same length.
Okay, so that's our X values, our market
returns, so our Y values are just going to
be the same sort of references, but in
column G.
So, from cell G2 down to cell G2165.
Then we're going to press OK and OK again.
Scroll back to the top of the chart.
And we can see that we've got sort of a
baseline chart here that looks somewhat
like the scatter plot chart that we've got
for Sanderson Farms above.
There's a few things we need to do to tidy
this up, though.
The first of which is move our X and Y
axes to the edges of the chart.
So, we want the Y axis that's in the
center here over to the left and the X
axis in the center here down to the
bottom.
So, to do that, I'm going to double-click
the Y axis first, go to labels on the
right-hand side in this format axis panel
and choose label position as low.
Then we're going to do exactly the same
thing for our X axis, so double-click that
within this format axis panel.
I'm going to, so format axis panel within
the axis options tab, I should say.
I'm going to go to the labels section and
choose label position as low again.
Okay, so that's looking quite a lot
better.
Another thing I think that we should
probably do is increase the text size of
these X and Y labels.
So, I'm going to click on the Y axis
again, go to home on the ribbon and just
knock up the text size.
Probably to 10 points for this one and the
same for our X axis as well.
Okay, next what we'll do is edit our
observation points themselves.
So, at the moment they're just all kind of
opaque blue circles and you can see in the
chart above standards and farms, they're
kind of a slightly transparent circle with
a border around them.
And the reason why I quite like showing
dot plots with a sort of transparent
center in the markers is just so that you
can kind of see when there's loads and
loads of them piled on top of each other
because the color becomes very opaque.
So, you can kind of see where the data is
really concentrated.
So, let's do that now with this series
here.
So, I'm just going to click on that
series.
So, any of those data points and then in
the format data series panel on the right
hand side, go to fill and line.
Choose the marker options down here and
this is fine actually marker options can
stay as circles, but if we go to the fill
section of this tab, then we're going to
choose solid fill and just make the
transparency instead of 0% 50% and you can
see that that's changed the sort of
transparency of all of those markers in
that chart already.
Then I'm going to go to the border
section, click solid line, press OK to
making these changes as we're going and
make the border just the same color
basically and keep the transparency as 0.
So, that's fine.
That's basically all I wanted to do there
and now the charts looking pretty good.
It's we've pretty much done everything
that we need to do in terms of aesthetics.
We now need to move on to plotting the
kind of regression line, the line of best
fit that goes through all of this data and
also the regression equation that goes
with it.
So, to do that, I'm selecting this chart
again and I'm going to go to chart design
on the ribbon, add chart element, choose
trend line and linear trend line.
So, that's going to add a blue dotted line
and if I double click on that blue dotted
line, we can then format that.
I'm going to format it to a solid line
that is black in color instead.
So, it's a bit easier to see on the
background of all those blue data points.
And then within this panel, I can choose
the trend line options tab at the top
right here and choose to display the
equation of that line on the chart and the
R squared value as well.
So, I've just ticked those two checkboxes
here and you can see that the equation R
squared value has appeared there.
So, I'm just going to click and drag, left
click and drag that to the top right so
it's in the same position as we have it
for Sanderson Farms and then on the home
tab of the ribbon, just increase the text
size again so we can see that a bit more
easily.
Okay, so that's our scatter plot chart
done for Fluor Corporation and we've added
a simple linear regression line with the
equation defined in the top right.
Now is probably a good time to mention
what the R squared number is all about as
well.
Basically, that's a measure of how well
the linear model explains all of the data.
So, if the value is 1, it would explain
all of the data perfectly and in this way,
it's pretty much the same as what we saw
with values of correlation.
in the previous video, the greater the
dispersion around the line, the weaker the
model.
I include these numbers really only as a
reference, they don't necessarily affect
the value that we take for beta since we
know we're only estimating that based on
the data that we have anyway.
However, I do think it's interesting to
get a basic understanding of how well the
model predicts or fits the data.
Anyway, with that scatter plot chart done,
we can see the regression
equation equation we have to explain Fluor
Corporation's returns is 1.3999 times the
market return minus 0.0012.
From that, we know that the gradient of
the line and hence our beta value for
Fluor Corporation is at 1.3999 or let's
just call it 1.4.
Let's note down our two lifetime beta
values from the stocks that we're looking
at now.
And I say lifetime beta because the beta
values that we've estimated here are based
on all of the available data that we have
for these stocks going back in history.
So in cell V10, I'm going to type lifetime
beta and in the cell below that V11, I'm
going
to type equals 0.5656 or just 0.5656,
which is the beta value we have calculated
for Sanderson Farms.
And before we go any further, let's think
about these two beta estimates that we've
got and whether they actually add up with
our expectations.
Sanderson Farms is a poultry company and
that's clearly in the food processing
sector.
So we'd expect there to be demand for
chicken irrelevant of what's going on in
the broader economic cycles of both the US
and the rest of the world.
So from that perspective, I think a beta
estimation of well below one makes a lot
of sense.
And so I'm not too worried about a
significant error in that estimation
purely based on economic logic in this
instance.
Equally, Fluor Corporation is an
engineering business providing sort of
procurement, construction and fabrication
services worldwide with large segments in
energy, chemicals, mining and industrials.
And given those sectors drive the demand
for Fluor Corporation services, we should
expect that this company is quite
sensitive to the economic cycle based on
the fact that demand tends to fluctuate in
those areas based on willingness to invest
So again, this beta estimation of about
1.4 makes sense again and it sort of shows
that company profits and hence returns are
cyclical and more sensitive to the market
as a whole.
Now, you'll be pleased to know you don't
have to go through the process of building
a scatterplot chart every time you want to
obtain a beta value.
There are a couple of much quicker ways
that being said, I did think it'd be
useful to go through that charting process
as you might find some of the techniques
and ideas discussed useful in other
applications, as I said earlier.
So let me show you a quicker method now to
calculate beta by simply using a built in
Excel function called the slope function.
So let's assume we want to calculate the
two year beta for Sanderson Farms.
In cell V13, I'm going to type two year
beta and in the cell below V14, I'm going
to type in a formula which is equals
slope.
Within the slope function, you can see we
have two parameters to define.
This is just like we covered previously
with correlation, we need to reference two
arrays, one for our y values and one for
our x values.
And like I said, when it comes to beta,
our y values are always the stock returns
and our x values are always the market
returns.
And as with our correlation calculations
in the previous video, the reference
arrays must be the same length and over
the same period as well.
So in this instance, we want a two year
beta calculation, so we need to select
data from row two down to row 106 for both
columns F, the Sanderson Farm returns and
column E, which contain our market
returns.
That means the first array reference is F2
to F106 and the second one after a comma
is inserted is E2 to E106.
When we close the brackets and press enter
here, we can see that the calculation
returns 0.45 and that is our two year beta
estimate for Sanderson Farms.
Clearly, that estimate is a little bit
below our previous lifetime estimation
when we use the entire dataset available.
Again, this takes me back to some of the
things I said in the previous video
regarding the reliability of statistical
estimates.
They're by no means perfect, and they are
going to vary depending on the underlying
data used.
The time window that you use to estimate
things like beta and correlation depends
on the logic that you want to use and
potentially the availability of the data
in the first place.
I think whenever you're making a decision
on the observational data that you're
using for your analysis, always remember
the goal of your analysis in the first
place.
So for beta and correlation, we want to
use data that we think will give us the
best estimate of what those values will be
in the future.
Usually, that means finding a balance
between using the most recent data, which
arguably better reflects the current
economic environment for the firm,
whilst also making sure that there's
enough data points to enable statistical
rigor.
When it comes to beta, industry standards
vary between using sort of two to five
years of data on either monthly or weekly
frequencies.
But I would argue that really you should
be using weekly frequencies over any time
up to the sort of five year time horizon.
For the most part, lifetime values are not
used since both the sort of company and
economic conditions have likely changed
over that kind of length of period.
So with that being said, let's calculate
the three and five year beta now quickly
for Sanderson Farms.
So in cell W13, I'm typing three year beta
and in the cell below that I'm going to
type equals slope open brackets and then
I'm going to choose Sanderson Farm returns
going back three years.
So from F2 to F158 followed by a comma
followed by selecting our market returns
over the same period.
So that's E2 to E158 and I'm just typing
this in because it's a little bit easier
than sort of selecting to the correct row
in this case and then close brackets.
Press enter and then we'll move on to the
five year beta.
So in X13, I'm going to type five year
beta and in the cell below X14, I'm going
to type equals slope open brackets.
This time I'm using five years of weekly
returns data for each data series.
So we're going to choose from F2 to F262
for Sanderson Farm returns and in the
second parameter E2 to E262 for market
returns and then close brackets and press
enter.
So we can see here from these calculations
that the three and five year betas for
Sanderson Farms are 0.49 and 0.5
respectively.
So the values over all of these
timeframes, lifetime included, are
actually pretty close and in line with
what we would say our economic logic is
for this stock.
So there's definitely no sort of red flags
here.
One thing I would say, though, is that you
definitely don't want to get bogged down
in the kind of decimal places and sort of
accuracy to multiple decimal places of
beta when calculating it in various ways.
Any one of these calculations will
actually be good enough to use.
So don't worry too much about that stuff.
What I do want to show you, though, and
this is really for those of you that are
more statistically minded and perhaps
thinking of going into industry, is an
additional statistic that gives us an idea
of the statistical accuracy of the beta
measure itself.
And I'm not going to go through this in
detail because it is really beyond the
scope of this course, but you guys will be
able to look it up afterwards if you want
to.
And like I said, it might be useful for
some of you that are thinking of entering
industry.
So in cell V16, I'm going to type beta
space SE, which stands for beta standard
standard error.
Now, standard error statistics are a
little bit like standard deviations, but
they can apply to error terms in
statistical estimates.
So basically the value we calculate for it
effectively gives us a volatility for our
beta estimate.
And if we assume the error terms are
normally distributed, then we can apply
certain probabilities to ranges of beta.
So let's calculate the beta standard error
now then in cell W16.
The formula that I'm going to use here is
a long one and it's not necessary to
explain.
Like I said, I just want to show you
quickly how you can obtain the beta
standard error without dwelling too much
on it.
And you can always explore it more in your
own time if you want to.
So the formula is, and bear with me here,
equals index, open brackets, lin est, so
l-i-n-e-s-t, open brackets again, F2 to
F106.
Okay, we're looking at a two year beta
here, two year beta standard error, I
should say, followed by a comma.
The second parameter here is going to be
E2 to E106, followed by a comma, one
comma, one, close brackets, comma, two,
comma, one, close brackets.
Now, you might be thinking here, what on
earth is that equation?
Like I said, I don't really have time to
go into the formula and how it works.
You're going to have to take my word for
it that this does return the beta standard
error.
You can, of course, look up this sort of
formula in your own time and also more
about a beta standard error if you want
to, like I said before.
But anyway, you can see here that the
standard error value that we obtain is
roughly 0.15.
So if we assume that our errors are
normally distributed, then what we can say
things like there is a 68% chance that the
true beta lies within one standard error
of our estimation, meaning 0.45 plus or
minus 0.15, which is our two year beta
estimate with a range of 0.15 either side
of it.
So one standard error either side of it.
Alternatively, we can also say there is a
95% chance that the true beta lies between
0.45 plus or minus 0.3, which is two times
the standard error around the two year
estimate.
Now, if that all sounds completely
confusing to you, just forget about it
now.
It's irrelevant for retail trading
application.
That is just a small little segment I
wanted to add for those of you that are
more statistically minded or are just
interested in learning more about this
sort of stuff.
It's not worth me spending any more time
on because explaining it just isn't worth
the marginal benefit of doing so.
Really, all that matters is your estimates
of beta itself and not particularly
worrying about the errors in the estimates
themselves too much.
Just being aware that, you know, beta
estimates are subject to error.
That being said, there is one more thing I
briefly want to mention about how beta
estimates can be adjusted, which is
something that's sometimes used in
industry.
So sometimes a formula is used to smooth
out estimates of beta by multiplying them
by two thirds and adding one third of the
market beta.
The reason behind that is that in the
past, over long periods of time,
companies' beta values have tended towards
the market beta of one.
And not only is there some statistical
evidence of this, but also some economic
theory underpinning it, which is simply
that as businesses grow and mature, their
revenues and profits gradually diversify
to the point where the company starts
behaving like the average market firm.
There is also some statistical rationale
behind this adjusted beta measure, which
is that given the average market firm has
a beta of one, our best estimate of any
randomly picked firm's beta should be one
as well before doing any other
calculations.
So therefore the sort of weighted approach
of combining our best estimate of beta,
which is one with our calculated beta
estimation aims to reduce error on the
basis of those factors.
The split in weightings of two thirds to
one third is based purely on empirical
evidence of the trend of thousands of
companies beta over time using past data.
Now, you know, I'm not going to prove any
of that.
So again, you'll have to take my word for
it, but that sort of evidence does exist.
Now, my counter argument to using adjusted
beta in our circumstances anyway, is that
as traders, we're never seeking to take
positions for long periods of time.
So we don't need to be concerned with long
drawn out changes in estimations based on
kind of glacial shifts in company
dynamics.
So that being said, I don't think it's
going to make a huge difference whichever
way you measure beta on an individual
asset basis.
You can argue it in different ways.
And really what I aim to do here is give
you some supplementary information to
increase your knowledge.
And then the path that you choose is up to
you.
You can choose to ignore the additional
information on beta error and adjusted
beta that I've just given or look into it
further and potentially use it.
Or for you guys thinking about industry,
obviously, you can take note of it and
bring it up where appropriate on your
career path.
For most of you, I don't think it's going
to make a difference.
Again, I would say some of this stuff is
relevant for you going in for those of you
going into industry, but that's about it.
Okay, so I'm not going to go into the
process of calculating two, three and five
year betas for Fluor Corporation because
it's just exactly the same methodology as
we used just now.
And you guys understand how to do that by
now, I'm sure.
I will make sure to include it in the
download file, though.
And we are about to calculate those same
values anyway in the next sheet for a
slightly different purpose.
Okay, let's now take a quick look at the
next sheet, which is a beta time series
sheet.
In a way, there's nothing new here.
What you can see here is the S&P 500 and
Fluor Corporation returns along with a
rolling calculation for two and three year
betas.
Now, these rolling calculations are run in
exactly the same way as I ran rolling
correlations in the previous video.
But that being said, because we are using
a slightly different function here to do
it, I am going to quickly go through the
process again for a five year rolling beta
instead, which we can then add to the
chart and I'll comment on it.
So to calculate the rolling five year beta
of Fluor Corporation, all we do is use the
slope function on the returns of FLR and
the S&P 500 index over five year time
windows running from the most current data
back as far as possible.
So in cell H1, I'm going to head the
column five year rolling beta and in the
cell below H2, I'm going to type equals
slope open brackets E2 to E262 as the
first parameter array and a comma.
And then the second parameter array will
be the range D2 to D262 and close brackets
that defines our Y observations as Fluor
Corp returns over the last five years.
So 260 weekly rows.
And our X values are S&P 500 returns over
the same timeframe.
Once that cell is inputted, we can copy
down the formula to row 1905.
The reason being that row 1905 is the last
row here is that the calculation, that's
the last sort of row that the calculation
can still make use of five years of
returns data in the previous rows.
So the rows below.
So now that we have our rolling five year
beta estimates, let's plot them in the
chart to see how they compare with our two
year and three year estimates.
To do that, I'm going to select the chart
and right click in the chart and choose
select data.
And then we're going to add a series.
The series name is just going to be set to
whatever's in cell H1.
So it's our five year beta estimate.
And the series values are going to be from
H2 to H2061.
Okay, so that's our rolling five year beta
estimates from row two to row 2061.
And the reason why we're selecting an
array down to that row instead of row
1905, which is actually where the data
ends in that column, is that we need all
of our data series that we're referencing
in the chart to be the same length, which
in this case is set to be equal to the
longest data series that's referenced,
which is our two year rolling beta series.
Okay, now that we've got our five year
rolling beta estimations added to our
chart, let's take a quick look at it.
Basically, what we can see and conclude
here is, again, similar to the comments I
gave in the previous video about rolling
correlations.
Firstly, it's pretty clear that beta
estimates can change and sometimes quite
significantly.
So that is something that, of course, we
need to be aware of whenever we're using
beta estimates.
Now, I already mentioned the positives and
negatives of using shorter and more recent
time windows for beta calculations
compared to longer windows.
So I'm not going to comment on that again.
But what I will say is that we can see
from the chart here that long time windows
or longer time windows clearly look less
volatile than shorter time periods.
But equally, they're less responsive in
times of change.
Now, each stock you look at will have a
different profile in terms of rolling
betas and some will be more volatile and
change more than others.
And as I said before, I think whenever
you're choosing the underlying data for
your estimation of beta, there is no right
answer.
You should just kind of strive to use a
time window that makes logical sense to
you, considering that you want a forward
looking estimate.
So, for example, you should think through
questions like, is your beta estimation
based on enough data?
Is the data recent enough to reflect the
current position of the firm and economic
conditions?
Does the data incorporate old and stale
data that perhaps isn't relevant now?
Is the period that you're grabbing data
from on the whole reflective of what we
think conditions will be like over the
period that we're looking to trade the
stock?
And I guess actually that's the big one
that you need to think about.
Like I said previously, and you can use
this as a guide, industry practice is to
typically use two to five year beta
values.
That is calculating beta from the most
recent two to five year returns data.
Now, don't panic yourself too much about
all of that.
You know, choosing what time period to
use, because like I kind of said before,
the variation in beta estimates that you
get might be quite small anyway.
And, you know, the most important thing
really is that you actually know how to
run your own beta calculations and that
you understand them so that you can then
apply them.
And speaking of application, so far, all
I've really told you in terms of how beta
can be used is understanding whether a
stock is likely to be economically
sensitive or not, and perhaps whether it
can be defined as a cyclical or defensive
stock.
Now, it's about time we looked at some
more concrete uses of beta and we're going
to do that now by looking at beta at the
portfolio level.
Okay, so let's go over to the portfolio
beta sheet now, and this is where things
become a lot more interesting.
Before I go through the sheet in more
detail, as a bit of an overview, portfolio
beta is basically calculated by summing
the weighted beta of all its constituents.
Where the weighted beta for each position
is its net weight in the portfolio
multiplied by its beta.
Now, all the same rules of analyzing beta
apply in the same way at the portfolio
level as they did at the stock level.
And by that, I mean, it still represents
the change in portfolio returns you can
expect for a unit or from a unit change in
the market.
So for example, a portfolio beta of one
suggests the market goes up by one
percent, your portfolio will also go up by
one percent.
But more important than worrying about the
specific percentage moves in your
portfolio is being able to have a general
understanding of the exposure your
portfolio has to the market.
When you run a long short portfolio, you
should always have an opinion on the
market as a whole.
And that's what the sort of macro analysis
section in this video series is all about.
And it naturally kind of dictates whether
you want your portfolio to be net long,
net short or market neutral.
When it comes to portfolio beta, a value
of greater than zero represents a long
bias, less than zero represents a short
bias and zero itself is market neutral.
Now, prior to this, you might have just
been thinking that your net cash exposure,
that is your dollar exposure of your longs
minus your shorts would represent whether
your portfolio is long, short or neutral
to the market.
Now, don't get me wrong, that is worth
monitoring.
But the problem with that method is that
it doesn't take account for the risk or
portfolio or sorry, or volatility of the
portfolio's constituents.
Portfolio beta is a much more accurate way
to understand your exposure to the market
as a whole than just your net dollar
exposure.
For example, putting on $50,000 into short
positions and $50,000 into long positions
means you're dollar neutral.
But you might not actually have market
neutral exposure once you account for the
risk and volatility in your positions as
measured by beta values.
Let's make things simple here in an
example so I can make myself clear.
Let's say you allocated $50,000 to the
long and short size of your portfolio, but
your longs all have beta values of two and
your shorts have beta values of 0.5.
If the market moves down 1%, then your
longs are estimated to lose 2% or $1,000
and your shorts are only estimated to gain
0.5% or $250.
That's a net loss of $750 or 0.75% in the
portfolio purely based on market
movements, which doesn't sound very market
neutral, does it?
That should provide the key motivation
really for understanding your portfolio
beta.
It's very important to have an idea of how
your portfolio is positioned in terms of
being net long, net short or market
neutral so that you can make sure that it
aligns with your fundamental
predisposition in the sort of macro
analysis that you do.
And by the way, if you have been sort of
put off so far with the sort of fact that
beta estimates can vary quite
significantly and are prone to error,
don't be for this because at the portfolio
level, the error is much, much tighter.
And so portfolio beta measures tend to be
more accurate than individual stock betas
themselves.
And there is statistical proof of that
fact, but it's not worth going into in
this video.
And so again, you're just going to have to
take my word for that.
Now, obviously these estimates of beta at
the portfolio level still aren't perfect.
But what I'm saying here is that they are
more accurate than estimates at the asset
level.
Okay, so that's the goal of this sheet,
calculating and understanding your
portfolio beta so that you can position
yourself appropriately based on your
fundamental views and your conviction in
those views.
As well as monitoring portfolio beta to
understand your exposure to the market,
this sheet will also give you more of an
understanding about which of your
portfolio positions carry more or less
risk than others.
And monitoring these aspects should then
be checked against your own fundamental
views and convictions.
And then adjustments should be made
accordingly if the portfolio structure
isn't balanced in the way that you'd like
it to be.
So let me walk you through this sheet
piece by piece now.
As in the spreadsheets I've used in the
previous videos, the only cells you need
to edit in this sheet are the orange ones.
And they help define the positions in your
portfolio and the allocation to them.
The rest of the cells are all calculation
cells and so shouldn't be edited.
In terms of the layout we've got here, the
top section from rows 1 to 15 represent
the long side of the portfolio.
And the section below from rows 16 to 30
represent the short side of the portfolio.
Beyond that, right at the bottom, there's
an aggregate section for the total
portfolio.
Working from left to right now, I've split
the sheet into two sections.
The blue section holds user inputs and
calculation values that represent the
current portfolio situation, or the one
being modelled at least.
And on the right hand side, there is a
green section that represents potential
target scenarios such as risk parity, beta
parity and equal weighting.
And I'm going to talk about those shortly.
So let me briefly run through the user
inputs in this sheet.
In columns A and B, you can fill in the
company name and ticker for each portfolio
position that you have.
In column C, you need to enter a value of
beta for each position, which can be
calculated in any of the ways that we've
sort of looked at in the first section of
this video.
Beyond that, in columns D and E, the
current price and number of shares held in
each stock should be entered.
And finally, if you're looking to use any
of the target scenarios in the green
section, you'll need to enter your dollar
target gross exposure in cell J33.
So that value should basically be the
gross exposure you want for the entire
portfolio, which is, you know, the sum of
the gross value of all your positions
added together.
That isn't the same as your margin,
though, by the way, because you may well
run a leverage portfolio where the overall
value of positions you hold is greater
than your total margin.
If you're confused about that, then
hopefully it will become clear when we go
through the calculation cells in the rest
of the sheet.
So before I move on to looking at the
calculation cells in more detail, let's
consider the portfolio scenario I've set
up here currently.
It should look pretty familiar to you guys
because it's the same long short portfolio
from the previous videos.
I've calculated beta values for each of
these stocks and obtained their current
prices as of the time of filming.
And so all that's left here to do is
allocate some shares to each one.
Now, if you remember back to this
portfolio scenario in the previous videos,
we assumed an allocation of $10,000 to
each position.
In reality, you can't just choose to
allocate a nice round number like that to
a certain stock and assume that it's going
to be possible because positions need to
be built up by being long or short a
number of shares, each of which carry a
certain price.
So only if the share price is a divisor of
$10,000 would you be able to allocate
$10,000 to a position nice and neatly.
However, of course, what we can do is go
long or short the number of shares that
gets us closest to an overall exposure of
$10,000 for each position, which is what
we're going to do now.
So the way we do this is just by dividing
the allocation to each position by the
share price and rounding it to the nearest
whole number.
So, for example, for the VTRS position
here, let's use a formula to calculate
that in cell E3.
And that formula is just going to be
equals round open brackets 10,000 divided
by D3, cell D3 comma 0 close brackets.
What this formula does is use the function
round to round a certain value to a
desired number of decimal places.
So inside the round function, the first
parameter is the number that you want to
round.
So in this case, that is 10,000 because
we're looking to allocate $10,000 divided
by the current share price in cell D3.
And the second parameter is the number of
decimal places that we want to round to.
And assuming we don't have access to
fractional shares here, what we need to do
is round the number of shares to the
nearest whole number,
which means the number of decimal places
required is zero.
So hopefully that makes sense.
And you can see when we enter that
formula, the number of shares required for
this position is 725.
Now, instead of running that formula for
all 10 positions, I've actually created an
automatic target scenario in the green
section,
which tells you how many shares are
required in each position to achieve an
equal dollar weighting across all of the
positions in the portfolio.
All you need to do is make sure that you
have a target portfolio gross exposure set
in cell J33.
So we know for this portfolio that we've
got 10 positions, each with a value of
$10,000 roughly.
And so we're kind of targeting a total
portfolio exposure of $100,000.
And you can see here that I've already
entered that value into J33.
And so if we take a look at column N now,
you can see the number of shares required
in every position to achieve equal dollar
weightings.
From there, if we want to implement that
in our portfolio model, we can just copy
across those values into column E,
which I'm going to do here in turn for
both the long and short sides of the
portfolio.
Now, when you do this, you must make sure
you paste the cells as values into column
E.
We don't want to copy across the formulas
from column N, just the output values
themselves.
So as we've done before, this is just done
by right-clicking in the cells you want to
copy down.
Or sorry, selecting the cells that you
want to copy and pressing Ctrl C or
right-clicking and clicking copy.
And then right-clicking the cell that you
want to copy down from and selecting paste
as values as the option from the menu,
which is the clipboard option with the
one, two, three on it.
When we do that, for both the long and the
short positions, you can see that all of
our calculation cells in columns F to I
have populated.
So let's move on to what those mean now.
In column F, we've got a calculation for
dollar net exposure in each position.
That is simply just the current price of
each position multiplied by the number of
shares multiplied by one for longs and
minus one for shorts.
Column G calculates the gross exposure for
each position and is almost exactly the
same.
The only difference here is that it
doesn't adjust for long or short
positions.
So you can see here in both columns F and
G that we've achieved an almost equal
dollar exposure to all of our positions
based on the number of shares inputted for
each stock in column E.
It isn't exact, of course, because we've
got rounding issues as I mentioned before,
but it is close.
Now in column H, we have the net weight of
each position in the total portfolio.
This is the net exposure for each position
divided by the total gross exposure in the
entire portfolio.
And again, this shows that we've pretty
much got identical dollar percentage
weightings across the board.
And finally, in column I, I've calculated
what is called the net weighted beta for
each position as a contribution to the
total portfolio.
So these numbers are computed by taking
the net weight of each position multiplied
by its beta.
And when you add all of these values
together, you get the overall value for
portfolio beta.
And so by definition, when taken
individually, they give you an idea of
where risk is skewed to in the portfolio.
So, for example, since the values are a
function of betas and weightings, we know
that a relatively large value for net
weighted beta in a certain position means
that either one or both of the allocation
to that position or the beta of that
position is large.
And by definition, that in turn suggests
that the risk carried in that position is
also large.
Okay, so let's now look at the aggregated
calculations for these columns.
Cells F15 and F30 show the dollar net
exposure for the long and short sides of
the portfolio respectively.
And when you add them together, you get
the total dollar net exposure in the
portfolio, which in this case is around
$20,000 seen in cell F33.
That makes sense because we've got six
long positions all targeting a $10,000 net
exposure and four short positions each
targeting a minus $10,000 net exposure.
And so when you sort of add all of that
together, you get a value of $20,000
overall.
Similar calculations are run at the
aggregate level for gross exposure in the
adjacent cells.
And in this case, we see roughly $60,000
of exposure on the long side and almost
$40,000 on the short side, which taken
together equates to nearly $100,000 total
gross exposure for the portfolio.
In cells H15, H30, and H33, we have
aggregation cells that translate the net
exposures from column F into percentage
weightings by dividing them by the total
gross exposure of the portfolio.
Effectively, these cells show you the
percentage weighting in dollar terms
assigned to the long and short sides of
the portfolio.
And again, when these are summed together,
you get the dollar net weight at the
portfolio level, which tells you whether
you're long or short biased in terms of
dollar exposure and how much as a
percentage of total gross exposure.
That same output can also be achieved
simply by dividing the total net exposure
by the total gross exposure, if that makes
more sense to you.
Finally, in column I, we have aggregations
of weighted beta.
Cell I33 is probably the most important
cell in the sheet because it tells you the
beta of your portfolio given all of the
other inputs that you've defined.
And we can see this portfolio structure
has a beta of 0.3, which suggests it's net
long the market.
And we could estimate that if the market
increased by say 10%, our portfolio would
increase by around 3%.
That might sound boring to you, but
running a long short portfolio usually
means you're hedged against the market
movements, at least partially.
And so it's very likely that you're always
going to have a beta somewhere between one
and minus one.
And I would expect that even more likely
is that that value will be somewhere
between 0.5 and minus 0.5.
As I said in previous videos, though, it
doesn't necessarily mean that you should
expect less return than the market for
many reasons, such as, you know, the
ability for this long short strategy to
perform in all market conditions, as well
as things like use of leverage.
And of course, your ability as a good
trader to generate alpha in each sort of
trade idea, meaning your ability to obtain
excess returns over that which is expected
for each position given its beta value and
the market fluctuations.
I'll talk a little bit more about that
later in the course when we get to
performance metrics.
Speaking of leverage again, though, if we
take this portfolio as an example, if you
have put these positions on only using,
say, $20,000 of margin, then you're
effectively five times levered since the
gross exposure of the portfolio is
$100,000.
So a 3% move in your portfolio then would
equate to a 15% move in your total account
margin.
Now, I know that under current rules,
gaining that sort of leverage, at least in
the US, isn't possible unless you're kind
of using options or futures.
But you get the idea of what I mean here.
The reason we build long short portfolios
is to create a strategy that can succeed
and build wealth in all conditions.
And it also takes advantage of things like
low correlations.
And so in turn, it achieves better risk
reward dynamics.
And that strategy can always then be
levered up using various financial
products to get closer to the kind of
returns that you want to achieve.
Anyway, I don't want to dwell too much on
leverage since we talk about it in other
areas of the course.
Okay, so as well as beta being useful to
gauge the overall market exposure your
portfolio is carrying, we can also see how
positions are contributing to the value of
portfolio beta.
So in this scenario, on the long side, we
can see that XPO is carrying over 2.5
times as much risk as TTC, since its value
for net weighted beta is over 2.5 times as
large.
And if we look at why that might be the
case, we know that the dollar weightings
in the positions of this portfolio are
fairly even.
And so the additional risk with XPO must
come from its value of beta.
And when we look across, we can see that
that's true.
XPO's beta measures high at about 2.17,
whilst TTC is quite low at 0.83.
So the profit and loss in the XPO position
is likely likely to be much more volatile,
purely based on market fluctuations, which
is why we attribute more risk to the trade
as it stands.
Now that isn't necessarily a bad thing.
It's all really down to the sort of
conviction level that you have for each of
your ideas.
And I'll come back to that in a little
bit.
Now on the short side of things, it's
looking a little bit more even.
All the net weighted betas are ranging
between minus 0.155 and minus 0.121.
And so by that logic, the risk is fairly
evenly distributed across those positions.
Okay, so hopefully you now understand a
bit more about what net exposure is, what
gross exposure is, how portfolio beta is
calculated, and also how it can be
analyzed both in terms of portfolio
exposure and understanding the
distribution of risk between positions in
the portfolio.
With that in mind, let's talk through a
few scenarios now, and I'll discuss how
you can use some of the functionality I've
built in the green section of this sheet
while we're at it.
So first things first, for the current
setup we have, I've already showed you how
you can use column N to identify the
shares required to reach equal dollar
weightings in each position.
However, now we've implemented those
weightings into the portfolio, we can see
that risk is distributed unevenly across
all of our positions based on our net
weighted beta calculations.
Let's say now that for whatever reason we
want to assign an even amount of risk
based on values of beta to every single
position in the portfolio.
So, this is a scenario calculation that
I've made in columns J and K, and I've
called this scenario risk parity.
And by the way, there are many
professional firms that actually run this
kind of sort of position sizing strategy,
although, granted, this is a much more
simplified version of it.
So, column J uses a fairly complex formula
to calculate the gross percentage weight
required in each position to achieve this.
And then column K uses whatever target
gross exposure you've set in cell J33 to
calculate the number of shares in each
position required to achieve those
weightings.
So, let's have a look at what happens when
we copy those share values across into the
portfolio now.
For our long positions, I'm just going to
copy cells K3 to K14 and paste them as
values into cell E3 by right clicking
within that cell and choosing the paste as
values option from the menu.
Again, I want to stress that for this
procedure, you do need to copy and paste
the cells as values, otherwise the
spreadsheet won't work.
After doing that, I'm just going to do
exactly the same for the short side of the
portfolio.
Okay, let's have a look at what's happened
here.
If we start in columns F2H, we can see
that the dollar allocations to every
position has changed and they're no longer
even.
Lower beta stocks have higher exposures
and vice versa in order to kind of
distribute risk evenly.
By assessing the values in column I, we
can see that this has been achieved quite
well since every position has almost
exactly the same value of weighted beta.
If we take a look at our dollar net
exposure and our portfolio beta, we're
still net long by both accounts.
So what have we actually done here?
Well, all this strategy does is basically
define the risk for each stock based on
its value of beta and then assign a
percentage allocation to each position
position so that the weighted risk of each
position becomes the same across the whole
portfolio.
If we had the same number of longs and
shorts in the portfolio, this would mean
we have a market neutral portfolio in beta
terms, i.e. a portfolio beta of zero.
But in this case, we have more longs than
shorts.
So the portfolio beta is still net long
measuring 0.27.
So the next question is, is this useful to
us?
And my answer to that is yes and no.
It's useful to act as a starting point for
position sizing.
But logically, to keep these weightings,
you would have to say that you have
exactly the same level of conviction for
every trade.
The reality is that that's going to be
very unlikely.
You're always going to have stronger and
weaker fundamental theses and these
convictions will change based on price
action as well.
Now, aside from ignoring conviction,
another downside of this strategy is that
the only way you can actually control
portfolio beta and hence market exposure
is by either adding or removing positions
rather than adjusting weightings.
Now, we can improve on this slightly by
looking at columns L and M, which model a
scenario I have called beta parity.
In this model, the weightings are risk
adjusted in each side of the portfolio
rather than the portfolio as a whole in
order to achieve beta neutrality at the
portfolio level, meaning a portfolio beta
of zero.
So in column L, the gross weightings are
worked out in order to risk adjust all the
weightings on the long side.
In this column, the weightings are worked
out in two sections.
So all the long weightings add up to 100%
and all the short weightings add up to
100% as well, rather than the combination
of both sets of weightings summing to 100%
as per, you know, we saw in the risk
parity model.
Those weightings are then used to
calculate the number of shares required
for a portfolio with the target exposure
set in cell J33.
If I copy those values into the portfolio
now, you can see that market neutrality is
achieved with a portfolio beta close to
zero.
And as it happens, the way this
calculation works also means that dollar
neutrality is achieved as well.
Now, obviously, portfolio beta and the net
dollar weight in the portfolio aren't zero
exactly, but that's purely due to kind of
rounding and the fact that we can't buy
fractional shares, as I've mentioned
before.
Now, I think this is a slightly better
scenario model to work from as a baseline
for positioning in the portfolio, since it
starts with the assumption of market
neutrality and risk parity within each
side of the portfolio, both the long and
short sides.
Now, really, these scenario models are
there just as kind of head checks and
guides to show you what your portfolio
would look like if all you had were some
position ideas, but no real conviction
about the market direction or which ideas
were better than others.
The reality is that you should have a
fundamental view on the market, and you
should have trades and ideas that you have
varying levels of conviction for, because
that's only natural.
So to that end, and to conclude the video,
I'm not trying to persuade you by any
means that you should be creating a risk
or beta parity strategy in your
portfolios.
Those are just interesting kind of
baseline scenarios from which to work
from, and I use them to help explain how
this portfolio beta model works.
What you really should be using this sheet
for is primarily monitoring your current
portfolio and modeling any changes you're
thinking of making.
And when monitoring your portfolio, you're
looking for a few things.
Firstly, at the portfolio level, you want
to know what your net dollar exposure is
and weight is, and also your portfolio
beta.
The beta value is the most important here
because it's going to provide you with a
more accurate idea as to whether your
portfolio truly is net long, short or
neutral, and by how much as well.
For most well-balanced long, short
portfolios, I would expect beta to range
from probably minus 0.3 to plus 0.3, but
that range can widen if you're taking on a
lot of leverage as I kind of discussed
before.
You need to make sure that your portfolio
beta is in line with your fundamental
outlook on the market as a whole.
And if it isn't, then adjustments will
have to be made.
And that might mean adding more weight to
certain stocks or adding or subtracting
entire positions as well.
Drilling down from the sort of aggregate
portfolio level, you should also be
monitoring the relative risk carried by
each position through the net weight, that
net weighted beta calculations in column
I.
And remember, these values are added up to
create the overall beta value for the
portfolio.
And so numbers with larger magnitudes,
whether positive or negative, carry more
risk.
You need to make sure that you know what
positions are the ones that are carrying
more relative market risk and also that
you're happy for that to be the case.
Again, if you aren't, then you will want
to make some adjustments.
And a final point here about monitoring
your portfolio in this spreadsheet is that
it goes without saying that even if you
keep the same positions for a long period
of time, the prices of stocks and
therefore weightings as well as the
estimations of beta will all move around.
And so the sheet does need continuous
updating.
And I would say that it's probably
sensible to update the spreadsheet on
either a kind of weekly basis or perhaps
every other week.
And the same actually goes for the
spreadsheets that we've looked at in the
last few videos as well.
Now, when you're thinking of adding and
subtracting positions from the portfolio,
you should model how this will affect
portfolio beta as a whole and use the
information inside the sheet to aid
decisions on weightings.
However, just like I said in the previous
video, this shouldn't be your sole
consideration when making structural
changes to the portfolio.
All trades must first and foremost come
from solid fundamental ideas with good
technical timing.
And that will help create a conviction for
each and every position.
And that is the kind of relative starting
point really for position weightings.
After that, you should overlay how that
actually fits into the portfolio using
this spreadsheet and conduct a head check
to see if you think the position and
weighting choices that you've made are
sensible.
Now, I want to make a really important
point here, which I touched on earlier,
but it might not have been clear enough.
Beta values represent the expected
exposure of a position or portfolio to
market movements.
But the returns of the position and the
portfolio are driven by more than just
broad market forces.
So when I say the market moves by one
percent, if your portfolio beta is one,
then you should expect your portfolio to
move by one percent in the same direction.
That's true, but only from a market
exposure point of view.
That's what would happen if your positions
are kind of distinctly average.
If your ideas are high quality and
generate alpha, that is excess returns
above those expected by market movements,
then your portfolio should perform a lot
better than whatever your beta value
essentially predicts.
Of course, we want to do this at an
absolute minimum, but what we're really
trying to target here are positions and
portfolios that generate consistent
absolute returns on top of alpha.
So in our portfolios, we basically want to
accept some level of market risk, as we
always want to have a view on the market
as a whole, whether long or short.
We want to make outsized returns above
market expectations predicted by beta,
both on the way up and the way down.
But when we outperform on the way down, we
want to try and make sure that
outperformance never translates to losses.
So if the market goes down by 10% and our
beta adjusted performance is say minus 5%,
we are outperforming the market, but we're
still losing money.
We want to target absolute performance,
meaning consistent positive returns, not
just outperformance.
We also typically want to use a sensible
or acceptable amount of leverage to
magnify portfolio volatility or exposure
and hence returns when markets go up and
down.
This course is built to help you get
outsized absolute returns.
So don't think that your portfolio is
hamstrung to perform in the way that your
portfolio beta predicts because it isn't.
Beta is just there to tell you your
exposure to the general direction of the
market, i.e. your market risk and where
risk lies in the portfolio,
which aids with things like position
sizing of individual trades and so on.
It's not there to predict your overall
returns.
So that's the end of the video.
I hope you guys got plenty from it because
once you fully get to grips with the
concepts in this video and the last couple
as well,
you're going to have some really good
knowledge and clarity about how to build
high quality portfolio structures.
And it should give your stats a really
good boost over time as well.
So that's it from me and I'll see you
later in the video series.